I've spoken on this channel a bit before
about things you could do after a
physics degree and I thought I'd ask
some of my friends who are all doing
PhDs in physics what some of their plans
or ideas are for after they finish I've
kind of heard from a few people that the
PhD in terms of your academic career is
the time when you have the most research
freedom when you can just focus on
finding out new things after that if you
stay in academia at least you get more
and more paperwork until you're not
really so engaged actively in the
research anymore so if you're currently
a PhD student try to enjoy that time
where you you can pose questions and
find the answers to them and then see
where you end up so the first obvious
one is academia but the many people who
don't get into academia there are many
industry jobs a lot of physicists go
into coding or software development even
banking and financial you can do a lot
of things with their physics degree if
you want to definitely in a PhD in
general especially in physics you learn
problem-solving you have this great like
combination of like this long term
problem that you're working on for three
or more years that you have to break
down into a bunch of little problems and
tackle those and you learn different
skills you learn a bit of programming
you have to learn how to communicate
properly you have to learn how to like
analyze millions of events at the same
time in a nuclear data set so yeah any
of those would probably help so yes I
would love to continue research and I
would love to like probably at this
stage I think I would love to go down
the academic kind of career but I'm very
realistic about the fact that I heard
0.5 to 5 percent of PhD students
actually have a career in academia so
while that's what I would like to do I'm
keeping my options open and like I'm
looking I'm always on the lookout for
other people I encounter outside of
academia and what kind of careers
they've had a what kind of job they're
in just at the moment just to kind of
look at the skills they have and see if
I can develop those while I'm doing my
PhD I'm pretty optimistic and I do think
the sky is the limit as a researcher you
are a general-purpose
industrial-strength problem solver and
so you're not necessarily limited to
solving problems in physics anymore one
of the things that I've gained from my
PhD there's a kind of intellectual
fearlessness where I'm no longer
intimidated by something that I don't
understand and that opens up a lot of
possibilities a lot of people like
working with people like that because I
mean they're just determination to crush
through a problem that you've never seen
it's can be hard to find so as to what's
possible a lot anything that requires
intensive data analysis understanding
complicated problems or designing
interesting solutions there's a places
where you can go and I'm being general
here because we are very generally
generally applicable people and it's
nothing to keep in mind if you want to
be an academic sweep if you want to be
an industrial research if you want to be
data consultant okay you can do probably
all of those things and there's a lot
more that's that's possible and you can
unlock it by doing physics there is the
option of continuing an academy on and
I'm considering that I'm also but I
don't necessarily want to go overseas
we'll see how that goes
but in Australia I am interested in
doing a lot of things and data analysis
trying to solve tricky solutions and you
know it's about it really
[Music]
you